if you understood that you could
dissociate all of your attention from
this three-dimensional reality and have
no attention on anything known and
understand it's the field that creates
matter that matter that emits the field
and if you could get to that place and
change your energy with a clear
intention and elevated emotion your
heart starts beating in this beautiful
Rhythm like a drum we've measured it so
many times and when that occurs the next
thing that happens the heart informs the
brain it's safe to create now so the
person relaxes into the present moment
and then we see this like if you took a
big sheep you know in a blanket and you
went like that the energy of the heart
actually informs the brain to move into
these beautiful elegant states of alpha
brainwave patterns coherent Alpha and
that's saying what's the next dream what
is it the next what's the next
opportunity you want to experience
that's a state of creation hey hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today this is your
best believe life and learn how to
manifest things into our lives and
business enjoy
so now you have a Wi-Fi signal you got a
coherent brain that's a directive that's
a signal out and you got this coherent
heart
that's what draws it to us right
you combine those two and if there's a
vibrational match between your energy
and that potential in the quantum field
and you're feeling abundant and whatever
your brain Associates with being
abundant that's your call that's what
the creative process is this is the
creative Center the brain frontal lobe
actually says what would it be like to
be creative or abundant
I don't know what it'd be like to be
abundant well then go read a few books
on people who who actually became
abundant and realize it wasn't a
glorious process they failed miserably
they let they got betrayed they learned
a lot of lessons but they persevered and
what are the qualities
of that person that you could embody
that that's the key right because it's
it's not about wealth
it's who you become right because people
think it's about their wealth but it's
the becoming process it's the overcome
attracted that right of course so then
so then you got to turn the battleship
around because most people say I can't
feel grateful for my wealth because it
hasn't happened yet that's the hypnosis
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel grateful well that's Newtonian
that's three-dimensional reality that's
cause and effect the quantum you got to
feel it in order for you to experience
it okay so this heart becomes like an
amplifier and it sends that signal out
and that frequency can carry the thought
of your abundance can suffering cannot
carry the thought of your abundance lack
cannot carry the thought off your buses
it's a different frequency right we feel
different feelings like suffering we
think different thoughts all right so so
people can say I'm abundant I'm abundant
I'm abundant abundant all they want but
that thought is never making it to their
body because it's stopping at the brain
stem because the body's saying I'm
miserable I'm unhappy I'm in lack right
so so the affirmation doesn't work right
okay so let's go one step further yes
so if you practice this and you actually
understood you know what we teach this
pretty well but if you if you learned it
just like learning how to play handball
or learning how to hit a golf ball
learning how to dance to salsa if you
just practice The Forum you got really
good at it
if you're doing it properly then what
would be the outcome the experiment of
being abundant would be that you would
have to feel that feeling it's so good
at doing it with your eyes closed you
got to do it with your eyes open now why
because if you're feeling the feelings
of your emotions of your future
you're no longer looking for them
because you're in the future now your
body is so objective that it's believing
it's living in that reality where you
are abundant as long as you feel that
emotion you're not separate from it any
longer no longer and lack you're no
longer looking for it to Cur occur say
why hasn't it happened yet if you're
feeling abundant why would you look
so then our job then is to be able to
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body so okay so does that mean like you
should check your bank account tomorrow
and see if there's a half a million
dollars in it no
you keep tuning into that potential and
then here come the synchronicities yes
what's that that's feedback in your
environment the universe saying hey
Louis whatever you're doing all of a
sudden we are starting to create right
and I think it's so important for people
to remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their lives right so the victim is
saying I'm feeling this way because that
person or that circumstance or I don't
have any money is causing me to feel
this way that's my relationship with
money what that really means is I'm
using my lack to reaffirm my dependency
my addiction my conditioning that's my
relationship with money is that I put my
attention on money because I don't have
it so the relationship with money is of
course built on lack and so when they
don't have it they feel bad and what
they're really saying is my outer
environment my reality is actually
controlling the way I feel the way I
think so Lewis why are you in a good
mood today things are going good why in
a bad mood things are going bad today so
this unconscious program of
victimization is saying that that that
we're we're allowing our environment to
influence the way we feel and the way we
think isn't that isn't that what
victimization is and and the stronger
the emotion we have to our lack the more
we put our attention on the fact that we
don't have it right so then the person
has forgotten that they're creating
reality because what they're creating is
lack and they're creating more of it and
then they try harder and they force
harder and they can they're more
exhausted and their body's tired and
they're breaking down right so so the
experiment then is let's try it another
way let's create from the field instead
of from matter
can a coherent heart get a coherent
brain relax in the heart and energy
moves right in the brain we've measure
this thousand times and all of a sudden
the person moves into these beautiful
elegant brainwave states where they're
super creative right so the the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you draw that future to you so then what
is the synchronicity mean it means
whatever you're doing inside of you is
producing that effect outside of you pay
attention to what you did again so
generate a little bit more abundance
just do it for an experiment now when
the synchronicity happens do you think
you feel suffering or do you think you
feel a little excitement you feel
inspired right so then that
synchronicity is saying use this energy
use this feeling it should be easier for
you to feel this now and go back and do
it again keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
doesn't just happen by accident we
generate we generate abundance right so
then if you have an hour meditation
where you're tuning into your abundant
future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change your defaulted you're
back to the old energy and if you say
it's that person or that circumstance or
that bank account I'm going to say
you're back to the unconscious program
being a victim rule number two ask
believe and receive Jack Canfield hi
there I'm Jack Canfield and today I'd
like to discuss the power you're
unconscious mind has on your everyday
life now number order to fully
understand the power of your unconscious
mind you first need to understand the
difference between your unconscious mind
and your conscious mind your conscious
mind is the awareness you have in the
current moment examples of this are your
awareness of your surroundings your
current thoughts and your current
emotions the physical Sensations you're
experiencing in your body whether or not
you're hungry and so on your unconscious
mind is any information that's below the
threshold of your current awareness
examples of these are memories beliefs
fears and subjective maps of reality the
thing with your unconscious mind is that
it's very powerful and can without your
awareness direct the course of what you
do in your life and because of this you
must learn to choose your thoughts
effectively because your thoughts both
conscious and unconscious due to the Law
of Attraction are what are creating your
current experience of reality including
your level of success in every area of
your life at work financially your
relationship your health and your
happiness
now for centuries most people didn't
know the law of attraction even existed
until 2006 when a documentary movie and
book called The Secret was released
which I was featured in along with many
other teachers of this powerful law you
see I've consciously used the law of
attraction in my own life to create
amazing personal achievements and
business successes far beyond what most
people ever experienced and the good
news is you can too
let me give you an example out of my own
life
in the 1970s I was fortunate to be able
to meet and work with one of the great
pioneers in the teaching of the Law of
Attraction W Clement Stone he was a
self-made millionaire worth more than
600 million dollars
and I was hired to work in his
foundation and teach his principles of
success to school teachers to
incorporate into their classrooms and
after a year of working there he
challenged me to set what I call a
breakthrough goal a goal that would
Quantum bleep my success and would
require me to stretch and grow in order
to achieve it now at the time I was only
making eight thousand dollars a year now
that seems like a small amount of money
but in today's dollars that was about
fifty one thousand a year salary
for example back then a gallon of gas
was only 36 Cents in 1970. anyway I set
the goal to make a hundred thousand a
year which would be 640 000 in today's
dollars that's huge now I used
everything Mr Stone had taught me
affirmations my affirmation was God is
my infinite Supply and I'm happily
earning investing and spending a hundred
thousand dollars a year I use
visualization I drew a replica of a
hundred thousand dollar bill and put it
on my ceiling so I would see it the
first thing every morning when I woke up
it would remind me to close my eyes
repeat my affirmation and visualize
having that hundred thousand dollar a
year lifestyle so it took about 30 days
and then one morning in the shower I
have my first hundred thousand dollar
idea I had a book called 100 ways to
enhance self-concept in the classroom
and every time it sold I got a 25 25
royalty now if I could sell
400 000 copies of that book I would make
a hundred thousand dollars that's a lot
of books to sell but at least it was an
idea it was the first hundred thousand
idea that ever occurred to me and then a
couple of months later I had another
idea that even took that further if I
was selling the book If I was a
bookstore and I was selling the book I
would make a three dollar profit now to
make a hundred thousand dollars I'd only
have to sell three thirty three thousand
333 books and so we started a mail order
bookstore with one product my book and
eventually other people said well why
don't you sell other self-esteem
products so we ended up with a catalog
and then the University of Massachusetts
said we hear you have this catalog of
books you're selling we're having a
counselor conference could you come over
and bring your books and sell them to
the counselors so we set up a bookstore
we made two thousand dollars profit that
weekend I thought wow if I did that
every week somewhere that's a hundred
thousand dollar a year business the
other thing that happened is I was
making three hundred dollars a day as a
consultant going out and teaching to
schools and the friend of mine I started
talking and out of the blue I said what
do you make when you sell yourself out
for a day what's your what's your what's
your consulting fee he said I get
800 a day I said 800 a day how do you do
that he said I asked for it so I
literally raised my feet 800 a day so
now I'm tripling my income in terms of
that well to make a long story short at
the end of the year I did not make a
hundred thousand dollars I made ninety
two thousand three hundred and twenty
five dollars but we were blown away by
that and then I've added since then I've
done that with a million dollars I've
done it with selling a billion chicken
soups around the world was selling a
million Chicken Soup for the Soul books
in one day getting on the Oprah show and
now we're doing with our goal of trading
one million teachers and trainers to
teach the success principles now
interestingly the key strategies for
harnessing the law of attraction in your
life are many of the same principles and
practices that I write about in my book
the success principles behaviors like
taking 100 responsibility for the
outcomes in your life believing it's
possible repeating affirmations on a
daily basis visualizing your desired
results creating a vision board acting
as if maintaining a positive expectancy
practicing forgiveness and appreciation
meditating and developing a positive
money consciousness
because the Law of Attraction has become
so much a part of our culture let's take
a few moments to discover what it is how
it works and most importantly how you
can use it to create the life and the
results you want
now stated in its most basic form the
Law of Attraction simply says what you
think about talk about believe strongly
about and feel intensely about meaning
what you focus on you will bring about
in your life now our thoughts have
amazing immense power over our lives and
as such it's probably a good idea to be
intentional about the thoughts you put
out there the thoughts you think and the
words you say out loud and if you have a
specific life or career or financial
goals for instance why not focus your
thoughts on achieving that goal and
having that good outcome in your life
instead of complaining about all the
things you don't want now to focus more
easily I want to share a formula with
you that will get the Law of Attraction
working in your life and the formula
which is discussed in the movie in the
book The Secret is simply this ask
believe receive so let's begin with
asking it's very simple the key is to
focus on and ask for what you want
versus thinking about asking for what
you don't want remember what you think
about read about talk about and give
your attention to are thoughts that are
actually requests that you're sending
out to the universe so you must start
being intentional regarding what you
think about all day are you immersing
yourself in positive uplifting joyful
thoughts do you meditate and hold
pictures in your mind of what you want
in your life or are you frequently
criticizing yourself and others
complaining about your life and focusing
on your lack of abundance
you see feeling excited enthusiastic
passionate happy joyful loving
appreciative prosperous and peaceful our
thoughts and feelings that give off
positive vibrations so start
intentionally creating the future in
your mind feeling the feelings you'd
feel and then let the universe figure
out how to manifest it I always say you
figure out the what the universe will
figure out the how now after all it's
phenomenally good at aligning the
universe that's what I'm talking about
when I say it it's phenomenally good at
aligning the people the situations the
money the resources and the
opportunities necessary to bring about
your desired goals and the next step in
this formula is believe you've got to
believe you will get what you want and
then take action taking action is
actually part of belief so what does it
mean to believe you'll get what you want
it means maintaining a positive
expectancy going about your day acting
as if with certainty knowing that you
put your futures in a power that is
greater than yours and that it will
deliver what you want
so always act as if what you want is on
its way it's simply a matter of you
deciding with conviction that what you
want will absolutely happen now I know
this isn't always easy many people have
limiting beliefs which keep them from
allowing abundance and happiness in
their lives and if this describes you
realize that you must first change your
limiting beliefs into thoughts that
you're deserving you're worthy you're
lovable you're desirable and you're
capable as well as smart enough strong
enough attractive enough Rich enough
good enough and enough enough in all
different ways in every way you can
think about that matters to you of
course once you believe that you'll get
what you want the second part of the
belief stage is to take action taking
actions that would create your desired
result affirms your belief that what you
want is Within Reach after all you
wouldn't be taking action if you didn't
expect the future situation to show up
would you so you're taking action it's
actually a demonstration of your belief
to the universe and the final step in
the ask believe receipt formula is to
receive what you want by becoming a
vibrational match for it now what do we
mean by vibrational match it's that you
me and everyone on the planet is like an
individual radio station that's
broadcasting on a specific frequency if
you want to listen to Jazz you have to
tune your dial to a station to broadcast
Jazz not one that plays hip-hop or
country and likewise if you want more
abundance and prosperity in your life
you have to tune the frequency of your
thoughts your radio station what you're
generating out to the world and your
feelings to ones of abundance and
prosperity the easiest way to become a
vibrational match for what you want is
to focus on creating positive emotions
of love joy appreciation and gratitude
throughout the day you can also practice
feeling those specific emotions you'll
be experiencing if you already have what
you want for example example thinking
you don't have enough money to pay your
mortgage will create negative feelings
of fear and hopelessness even guilt and
shame for not being able to provide for
your family instead of giving energy to
these negative thoughts shift your
thinking to positive ones such as I will
find a way or the money will show up on
time and visualize yourself easily
paying the mortgage on time
at first this process may seem very
foreign to you but the truth is you can
over time learn to choose only uplifting
inspiring motivational and empowering
thoughts
trust me it's simply a habit that with
intention and discipline can be
developed rule number three is lean
towards Joy with Gabby Bernstein here's
the answer to this question that I think
is a universal question how do I
manifest or how do I how do I manifest
when things aren't going right in my
life when things are not going well
the bottom line is is that manifesting
isn't about getting anything manifesting
is about feeling good so even when
things are in their darkest moment even
when we're going through the most
difficult circumstances we have the
capacity to lean into moments subtle
shifts moments of Serenity moments of
gratitude moments of Faith moments of
relief moments of Joy even if it's a
split second that's enough so right now
you're here with me on dear Gabby this
is a moment of Joy you're really happy
to be here there's a meditation waiting
for you in your manifesting challenge
that is a moment of Joy so manifesting
isn't about
catapulting ourselves into feeling
perfect all the time it's about the
subtle shifts for radical change it's
about the subtle shift of feeling a
little bit better right now and then a
little bit better later and then a
little bit better later and just
continuously doing whatever it takes to
get closer to the level of heightened
awareness of that presence of Joy within
ourselves that doesn't mean that we are
walking around perfectly happy all the
time but it means that we are in the
pursuit of feeling good being a super
attractor isn't the person that's
manifesting billions of dollars all day
long and perfect things and perfect help
the super tractor is the person who
lives in the pursuit of feeling good
their deepest desire is to lean towards
joy that is our work as super attractors
as Spirit junkies as manifesters to
really show up for that inner sense of
Serenity and peace within ourselves so
that we can wake up one moment at a time
to the support that is within us and
around us also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is be in harmony with
everything with Bob Proctor applying the
law of attraction to to love in our
lives because I find that one of the
biggest Paradigm blocks that a lot of us
have and I know a lot of my listeners
feel challenged with is the finding of
love the keeping of love the growing of
love in a relationship with another
person it can be one of the biggest
challenges as you said our spiritual DNA
is perfect but our material experiences
in DNA comes with baggage and pain and
stress and we end up attracting or
vibrating at a level where we attract
something that that actually is what we
need at the time but isn't what we
really truly want tell me a bit about
your experience in that area in your
field or study in that area
I think that love
is resonance
when two people are in love
they're on the same frequency
intellectually emotionally and
physically
most people that get married are not in
love
they're inhabit
words that stay married are not in love
when two people are in love they enjoy
thinking about the same ideas
conscious mind deals with ideas
they get emotionally involved with the
same idea so they're setting up the same
vibrations
their heart is on the same frequency
and physically they enjoy doing the same
things they have a great physical
connection
that's when two people are in love
they're in harmony it's likely
emotionally and physically
you can fall in love with your business
I'm in love with the business that I'm
in intellectually mostly and physically
I'm in it
right up to here you know
so that's where I see love comes in I
think I don't think most people are that
are married or in love I think they see
each other and he thinks God she looks
pretty good and she thinks he looks
pretty good and they go to bed and they
go to heaven for 15 minutes and they say
we're in love well they're actually
having some fun
but they weren't in love
yeah but they thought they were and so
they get married and they have nothing
in common really
and some of them will
it was a marriage at quiet funeral and
get on with life and others will just
stay there and live like that but there
isn't any love there may be respect and
things like that
but I see love is when it's Harmony it's
resonance
um
you can love a person you can love an
idea you can love a vocation you can
love a place
you know
it's like Paulie Apostle he said the
greatest thing is love and he's so right
well that's when everything you're in
harmony with everything
in all aspects of your life rule number
five is practice repetitive Thoughts
with Ed mylett I used to walk this beach
as a kid and say this is where I want to
live someday I knew exactly what beach I
knew exactly the area and the more my
brain went to work on that specific
thought that specific place the more
likely it was to happen so remember this
the more specific you are with your
thinking the more intentional you are
with the thoughts the higher the
probability of it happening and your
brain can go to work that Ras can go to
work on finding the people places things
and resources to fill in that very
specific thought that you have so don't
be General be specific and repeat it
over and over and over again to yourself
you got a whole lot more likelihood of
happening the other thing is this your
brain likes to gravitate towards what
it's most familiar with the brain loves
familiar things okay so the more you
think about something the more you place
yourself on that beach in that house
with that amount of money with that body
the more repetitive it is that you place
yourself in those things those places
and those situations the more your brain
becomes familiar with it the more it
gravitates towards it you can't think
about it once it's the repetition over
and over again your brain begins to
think oh I belong here we belong here
you actually eventually convince
yourself literally that you belong in
your dreams by the repetitive and
specific thinking and visions of them
over and over again and rule number six
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is be grateful with Lewis
house this for me is part of the secret
to the Law of Attraction it's the
foundation is gratitude it's your way of
being must be grateful in order to
attract new things there's so many
things in my life that I should not have
attracted
because I didn't have the skills because
I didn't have the tools because I didn't
have the education because I didn't have
the money because I didn't have the
resources so many things that I
shouldn't have attracted but because I
had the foundation of gratitude
passion Joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
I have right now it can be that I have a
roof over my head that I've got quality
friends that I'm healthy you know that
I'm walking in nature today it doesn't
have to be some grandiose thing that's
happened to you to be grateful for I'm
so grateful for these little present
moments with people that I care about to
spend an hour on the beach to go for a
walk with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that I'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful the moments in
between the big moments are just as
meaningful so write down these things or
think about these things this is
something I embed in my daily life when
I wake up I think about what I'm
grateful for when I go to sleep I I
think about and reflect on the things
I'm grateful for from that day
the beautiful thing about monk life is
half the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never ever go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected whereas
when my morning routine is weakened I
feel weak and so for me the morning
routine as I get strategic about it
there's two principles you have to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you're full hungry you'll feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise I used to struggle a lot
with manifesting just the idea of it I
would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it uh
whether it's manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on a couch and think about money coming
into your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and do
the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust that it's already and then go
do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times it has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and just 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a speaker
in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly here
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too when
we talk about
or think about the law of attraction
before we even consider that law and
several other corollary laws
when we talk about everything is energy
what does that really mean
right like what does that really mean
when you think about you know we use
telescopes to look into outer space into
the cosmos and we use microscopes to
look deeper into material things until
it all disappears anyway right we can
see electrons and protons and muons and
quarks and leptons the Very fundamental
building blocks of nature of our body of
plants of the ocean of everything in the
known Cosmos and it appears
that everything is vibrating if you were
to look through these electron
microscopes you know deep into a plant
or even your hand although it appears to
be solid
um we see vibrating packets of this
thing we call Energy vibrating packets
of something called quanta right and so
if everything is vibrating
then is it possible and this is a
dialogue right is it possible that when
you and I have a thought
a positive one a negative one a thought
about something we want or something we
don't want right so it's a thought a
spark of electrochemical activity in the
brain of thought we say you know I want
this I don't want that is it possible
let's just have a little dialogue here
is it possible that since that thought
is a burst of electrical activity and
also releases a chemical that correlates
with that thought is it possible
that the electrochemical activity is
vibrating
oscillating moving whatever you want to
call it at a certain frequency
that resonates or repels with certain
things in the physical world is it
possible if everything is energy
um
how do you get into resonance with what
it is you want to you know attract how
do you get mentally physically
emotionally spiritually in resonance
with the stuff that you want instead of
what you don't want here's one of the
biggest challenges
our brains are wired for safety first
emotional safety physical safety
Financial safety first and so in order
to protect ourselves our brain actually
has to think about where is their danger
like where could I get hurt and in
thinking about where you can get hurt is
it possible that sometimes we're in a
temporary or permanent state of fear and
if we're in a permanent or temporary
state of fear is it possible that that
state of fear or uncertainty or
self-doubt is actually attracting
resonating with the stuff that we don't
want
one of the keys to applying the law of
resonance
is getting your mindset right the brain
right focused on what it is that you
want
getting your heart
right the emotions aligned as well so
it's head and heart aligned also with
what it is you want to resonate with
and then there's another piece to it
that not a lot of people think about or
talk about and that's the gut
right the brain gut access is in
communication with each other at all
times and there's a lot of research
around you've got to really follow your
instincts right your intuition your
instinctual feeling about stuff so you
got to get the head the heart and the
gut aligned and that is really the
winning combination to be in a state of
resonance your personality literally ad
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem that if you don't
know how to mediate or control your
emotional reaction to that event and you
keep that refractory period of chemicals
going on with extended periods of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened where it's
happening to you so the moment you open
your heart and you feel gratitude well
that emotion then is telling the body
that the experience has already occurred
and the thought then can make it into
the body because it's consistent with
the thought so now you're beginning to
program the autonomic nervous system
into a very specific Destiny you got to
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email then I would say oh my God
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life
unless of the victim of your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome my team
thinks that you should listen to this
video every single day go check it out
let me know what you think I'll see you
there I think the Law of Attraction and
manifesting are the same thing so Law of
Attraction for everybody who has not
read the secret is simply your thoughts
become things and it's true we've talked
all about how when you have a negative
self-talk it tends to draw more